dude we were dying at [__]
haagen-dogs last night what happened I
left
the people in line in front of us oh
yeah they may be a race from the boys
from the Eastern side of the world and
they were just taking so long to order
so Bobby starts to imitate them but it's
also you know not quiet so all you hear
is something going on yeah
no I was going excuse me please I was
screaming Point crash can I take every
breath it has nothing to do with the
accident we were opposite we were a
little upset because they're asking for
every flavor so they're taking so long
but then we we're a sample but we
realized we were wrong because it wasn't
really them then we realized it was the
thing the people that were working there
because they were even worse yeah so
what flavor you want yeah yeah then they
were I was like oh it was in the
Japanese people it's the [__] people
behind the counter no one could
understand each other that's why I took
so long I think that you're setting a
great example for like you know
the start Asian hate campaign
yeah you know you're right I mean for me
it's like when I see other Asians acting
not the way I want them to act right I
start like I'll go hard on them more
like because of like you have a higher
expectation to your people well I you
know I have a rule about any anybody go
waiting in line to get anything in terms
of food service right that's true
because you're he was [__] on
everyone because there's one couple that
went up to the line that's they were
waiting the whole time like us they say
what do you want they stop turn around
looked at the menu yeah and they had to
spend the whole [__] time so then I
said
you know what did I say I go when I
order I'm going to look at them
so I turned around I did exactly what
they did right just to get a laugh from
these guys but my point though is this
my point is this though is
um that um you know when I'm winning in
a big line right yeah let me ask you
something what do you think I'm thinking
of
if when you're the most important thing
who's the most important person if I'm
waiting in line who am I thinking the
most important person in the building or
people
um the wait staff no you no waiting in
line
um oh oh the person behind you exactly
yeah courtesy that's the only thing I
think about yeah and I want to look at
the person behind me and go wasn't that
quick
you're welcome I'm with you exactly but
people in front of me don't think about
me they don't think about me
you're right and I tell you every prayer
you know it's like what are you doing
think about me think about us doesn't
have to be an Asian that could be anyone
it could be anybody
because you're the same way right like
I'm exactly the same way like I I it
makes me anxious when I know I'm holding
up a line she wouldn't even ask for
extra creamer because I wouldn't because
there was a line behind me I like it so
I'm like no I'm [__] the creamer and
then I called Gilbert on my way home do
we have creamer at home because I and he
was like why didn't you ask I was like
there was a line behind me I'm not gonna
inconvenience them but probably also a
little bit codependent and not healthy
um I do want to ask you a really strange
question I don't want to
I know I'm going to listen to your
question I don't want to shy away from
this topic real quick though all right I
have one more thing to say okay I'm
sorry okay
here's another thing
if you're with a group
if in a line right yeah
order
together
pull your money together
and order together
because no no no you're correct if you
do it individually right it just takes
[__] forever especially if there's a
line right and you're like oh I'm sorry
you know we don't have money
[Laughter]
you waited like ah no but you know
they're like we don't wanna
like maybe one guy has a credit card you
know I mean I don't know what the
situation have one guy figure it out
Mike he did that you did that so the way
I do it in my family is we always send a
representative to line up so that the
line isn't like eight people longer so
we're all in line together the line is
longer it's confusing
um we choose a credit card and we move
fast I take the orders and I'm like this
this this this I'm out right yeah but
okay there's always I've had this
experience where there is always one
person like we split let's say we agree
to split the bill
I've had a person do this to me well I
didn't order the mac and cheese side so
I don't think we should split evenly I
gotta skip that whole thing you know
what you do in that situation you cut
that friend out of your life
you erase their number you look them in
the eye and go this is no longer the
root a thing you cut the root yeah a
stable thing okay yeah I like that yeah
but I feel
with you if if it's like at uh let's say
I'm being real
you kind of my real life but I think
this is what do you know